yeah I don't understand why you haven't
been fired from that why you weren't
fired I don't understand that's because
you pisses on the balcony well first of
all we all are wondering why you do you
that it really isn't I mean what like
Ike Barinholtz says like I don't
understand a lot of people say I don't
understand why she's with me yeah this
is like you're like Donald Trump yeah
yeah we don't get why people are voting
for you we just don't understand what's
happening yeah yeah I don't and you're
the dumb public that's like we like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because I don't even think the dumb
public knows exactly what they love
about him they can't they can't what
they hate about everyone else what the
problem is
yeah you being with Bobby says one every
guy you've been with before you have
horrible taste in man like they must be
monsters okay you must have been with
like then you're just like if Bobby's
like a blessing man he is only because
people have anybody else that I've dated
in the past were just so [ __ ]
textbook perfect and boring it's like
you and those girls that were kidnapped
for ten years ago only ones that were
like here's my prince charming a little
bit of unpredictability in my life and I
like good stories to tell and in in my
law and I've been and rot long
relationships with very normal people in
the past and I just always found myself
bored out of my mind by myself like self
entertaining like I question that I need
to see a dossier of like your previous
boyfriend's know she dated teachers no
she the last guy she dated before me was
a Spanish professional soccer player
from La Liga she's
FIFA have you played with him before I
will never so you thought you wanted to
be with somebody that wouldn't cheat on
you then because he was cheating or
probably listen if he's a professional
soccer player he was getting a lot of
that wasn't something that I even care
oh yeah I mean it's not like really
really was getting a lot of blue keep
reminding her how much [ __ ] he was a
lot of bosom years unrealistic I was
kind of it was it was a lasted for a
year and a half that was sort of open so
a sort or not but those guys are very
like machismo so they don't want you to
hook up with other people and then when
I [ __ ] started dating they were you
went crazy yeah because the guy hangover
what yeah he said kalila you are losing
your mind I think you need to like enter
a mental institution because imagine you
don't know who I am at all yeah why
you're leaving you're in a different
country and then you just see a photo
yeah of a small fat disgusting looking
Asian dude you can there's probably six
more things you could say really yeah
because he's like a professional athlete
yeah believe me this is the only reason
why she did that
like at first she didn't really like you
she just wanted the biggest [ __ ] you to
him ever is let me see let me find the
most disgusting and then what happened
was she was like something right now
this is great like somebody drew you
[Laughter]
black dude I've ever seen anyway let's
move on I like you thanks for doing the
podcast I appreciate it I'm just doing
the podcast you just admit to him that
that was but
Luke why she's dating me we just did I
just answered all their questions we
know why she wanted to get back at her
professional high boyfriend because you
grew on her her shallowness was like you
know what she said to herself you know
what I don't need attractive anymore
yeah I don't need tall I don't need
anybody that could protect me in an
alley I don't need anybody they could
get things off the top shelf yeah I
don't need anyone that knows how to use
a toilet properly or I've had surgery
four days ago and not once has he so
much as taking care of me for an hour I
would just say this right now and that's
so first of all I come home right and
there's her mom her sister her ex guy
that used to see my best friend right
Jessica your best friend okay you know
that ugly-ass Korean girl you just saw
earlier come on moon face you sub moon
face she was here trying to eat her
mother but yeah you want to meet her but
yeah it's an experiment for them yeah
he's never in so it's like they're like
you're all spending the night so I slept
there up there yeah officer our whole
family is here you've dated a Filipina
you know just that we come in yes it's a
lot of family jewels and so we were all
spread out in the room they're all
taking care of me so you know how it
goes Eric so he didn't need to
[Music]